la mise sous cloche est elle sur le
point de voler en éclat aux pays bas le
tribunal de la haye a ordonné la
suspension pure et simple du couvre-feu
instauré jusqu'au 2 mars
pour les juges le gouvernement a abusé
de ses pouvoirs et n'a pas respecté le
cadre légal ni le principe d' urgence
particulière
les juges ont considéré qu'il y avait
une pandémie que le virus mute et que la
pression était forte sur le système de
santé
c'est une période inquiétante toutes les
décisions sont compliquées et des
mesures aussi drastiques doivent être
prises dans le cadre de la loi hope rôle
de catherine conséquences de cette
annulation des centaines de néerlandais
pourrait réclamer l'annulation ou le
remboursement des amendes reçues pour
non respect du couvre-feu
parmi les habitants de la haye les
réactions sont mitigées
je pense qu'il est très important que le
juge ait conclu qu'il n'y a plus de
raison d'imposer le couvre-feu tokyo
donc tout le monde est content j'ai vu
sur internet des gens explosé de joie
parce qu'il n'y a vraiment aucune raison
d'avoir un couvre feu
[Musique]
je pense que la décision appartient au
gouvernement et parce que c'est un
tribunal je ne vois pas le rapport
alors oui je pense que cela dépend plus
du gouvernement que du tribunal à
l'origine de la plante virus vareilles
de vérité sur le virus en néerlandais
un groupe opposé aux mesures de lutte
contre le coc vite 19 et pourfendeur du
couvre-feu
ce serait un peu étrange qu'une sorte de
petits groupes puissent déposer une
plainte et ensuite que celle ci soit
jugée recevable par les instances
judiciaires
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement a
commis une erreur dans le processus
d'instauration du couvre feu
donc c'est une situation vraiment
intéressante en ce moment
aux pays-bas le variant britannique se
propage de plus en plus et le nombre de
nouveaux cas augmente 25 1229 tests
positifs enregistrés ces derniers jours
contre 24 1668 la semaine précédente le
nombre de décès a aussi augmenté
face à la menace des nouveaux variants
le gouvernement néerlandais avait donc
annoncé début février sa décision de
prolonger le couvre feu national en
vigueur de 21h à 4h30 du matin
personnellement je comprends que
certaines personnes veuillent que le
couvre-feu disparaissent mais je penche
un peu du côté du gouvernement et avec
la circulation du variant britannique du
virus je pense qu'il est préférable de
faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
limiter la propagation du virus
[Musique]
ce couvre feu le premier aux pays bas
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale a
donné lieu aux pires émeutes qu'a
connues le pays en plusieurs décennies
400 arrestations en un week-end après
des affrontements entre contestataires
et forces de l'ordre
wilhem engel fondateur du mouvement à
l'origine du procès s'est dit soulagé
satisfait de son côté le gouvernement a
décidé de contre attaquer le ministre de
la justice a ainsi annoncé la rédaction
d'une loi d'exception
objectif maintenir le couvre-feu